let's talk a little bit about magnets
and magnetic fields and right over here
we have a picture of what today
we would call a magnet where we have
these metal nails all being attracted
to the stone and the stone the modern
name for it
is magnetite and human beings have known
about magnetite
for thousands of years in fact the name
comes from
ancient greece there was the magnates
people who settled
actually two areas that are often talked
about in the origin of the name magnet
which are now which are referred to as
magnesia
and depending on the historical count
you see it was one of those
magnesias where the ancient greeks were
able to find a lot of what we would call
magnetite and actually the element
magnesium which is not related to
magnetite
was also found in that area which is
where it got its name
but it wasn't just some interesting
thing that would attract metal
and they also obviously observed other
properties that if you had
two pieces of magnetized magnetite it
actually turns out that not all
magnetite is magnetized something
interesting has to happen to it we
believe it's actually lightning strikes
that magnetize it
naturally that the orientation matters
if you're in one orientation they might
attract each other
and then if you're in another
orientation if you were to spin this one
around they might actually repel each
other
and this notion of the orientation that
there might be some polarity
made it more than just an interesting
thing to observe
in ancient han china roughly 2000 years
ago they invented the first compass
where they realize that if you took some
magnetized magnetite which the
historical name for it is a
load stone and you allow it to freely
move and you could do that by either
hanging it from a string
or have it float on some still water say
in a bucket
that it will consistently orient itself
so that it points in the same direction
and so you can use that for things like
navigation which the
chinese did roughly a thousand years ago
and that helped us realize that the
earth
itself is acting as a magnet
and just like a small magnet has
different
sides to it the earth does too and
that's where the convention
for a north and south pole of a magnet
came from but there's probably a
question in your mind from the first
time that you noticed a magnet
if you have some piece of metal out here
that's not
touching the magnet and in a future
video we can even talk what touching
even means at a microscopic level
but if you have a nail out here that's
not touching it but there's some force
that's acting at a
distance on that nail how does that nail
know to be pulled towards that magnet it
doesn't have eyes it doesn't have ears
it doesn't say oh there's a magnet there
i better somehow
move myself towards it there's something
about that region of space
that is interacting with that nail or if
you think about two magnets
how does it know the orientation of the
other magnet to either be
attracted to it or repel it how does it
even know that other magnet is there
and that's where the concept of a
magnetic field
is useful and this was introduced by
michael faraday
in the 19th century as a way of at least
thinking about giving us a framework for
this force at a distance
it doesn't exactly tell us what it is
but it gives us a way of
predicting and thinking about what is
happening
and one way to visualize a magnetic
field
is to take a bar magnet or i could even
say a bar
load stone and put it underneath a piece
of paper
and then put metal filings on top of
that piece of paper
and you will see something like this in
fact i encourage you to do this to
observe this yourself
and you see what look like lines that
are essentially connecting
the north and south poles
like that and this notion of field lines
we can draw it a little
bit clearer in something like this was
introduced by michael faraday and he
says okay there's this thing
called a field that tells us for every
point in space
around the magnet what it would do to
something that is
interacting with the magnet another
magnet or maybe a piece of metal
so for example if you were to put a
small
bar magnet right over here the north
side
is going to be repelled from the north
side of this bigger bar magnet
and the south side is going to be
attracted to it and so what you could do
is you could put a freely moving
magnet or you could put a compass to
actually see what the orientation is
which direction will a compass point
and it will point in the direction of
these field lines and if you were to put
it over here it would orient this way if
you allow it to freely move where this
is the northern end and this is the
southern end and if you were to put it
here and you were allowed to freely move
let's say is part of a compass
and if this is the northern end and this
is the southern end it would orient like
that
and so that helps you draw the field
lines and also know the direction and
just by convention the direction
is we're coming from the north pole into
the south pole
and what faraday said is not only does
this tell you the direction of the
magnetic field
it tells you the magnitude based on the
density of these field lines so for
example
the magnetic field is stronger here
where in that
unit area that i just made you have very
dense field lines
while it would be weaker right over here
i have fewer feel lines now another
amazing thing about
magnets and their polarity that people
have noticed since ancient times is
you would think at least initially that
if this has a north pole
and a south pole then maybe you could
separate these two things maybe if you
were to break this in half
then you could have a pure north north
pole magnet and you could have a pure
south pole magnet but that's not what
happens when you break this in half
instead you have two magnets
each with their own north and south
poles and you can keep doing this and
early scientists just kept doing it and
said there might not be any limit to how
much you can cut this obviously
when you keep cutting and cannot cut any
more while retaining the properties of
the magnetite you're getting down to now
the molecular level
and in future videos we'll think about
how even at a molecular level
you can still have a little tiny magnet
that has a polarity to it now another
really interesting thing about magnets
is
this connection between magnetism and
electricity people have also observed
that if you took
a current carrying wire and the current
is going from the positive to the
negative end so it is going
in this direction and if you make it go
through a piece of paper that has metal
filings
it looks like field lines are forming
here
magnetic field lines it turns out it
does interact with the types of things
that tend to interact it will interact
with matte magnets and so this is a
magnetic field that is being formed
by an electrical current and so that was
the major clue that the phenomena
of electricity and magnetism are in fact
related and this relationship is what
allows us to do
things like have electric motors or
generate electricity
from wind or water turbines
and it's out of the scope of this video
but i'll give you a little bit of a clue
of how these things are connected
we know that things are made up of atoms
which are made up of
particles like electrons and protons
which are
charged and we know that a current an
electric current
is based on the movement of charged
particles
that when something is not magnetic say
a non-magnetic piece of magnetite all of
those charges are moving
more chaotically but if something
happens to it
maybe a lightning strike it can align
how they move
so that they act in concert to have a
more coherent
magnetic field so i'll leave you there
i'm already getting a little bit
for ahead of our skis so to speak but i
do think it's
really interesting to appreciate how all
of these puzzle pieces that we see in
nature
fit together